[Musique]
d'emblée des images des émeutes du 6
janvier pour lancer sa campagne une
pancarte pour le droit à l'avortement
devant la Cour suprême
liberté d'IDI Joe Biden d'une voix
éteinte car tout ce qui est en jeu selon
lui une vidéo de 3 minutes pour protéger
les acquisit-il que les républicains
seraient en train de mettre en péril le
droit l'avortement le droit d'aimer qui
ont jeu
[Musique]
après la bataille pour l'âme de
l'Amérique il y a 4 ans c'est sous le
thème let's fenèche de work finissons le
travail que Joe Biden entame sa campagne
électorale à 80 ans si l'emporte il aura
82 ans et sera le président le plus âgé
de l'histoire des États-Unis lors de son
inauguration déjà il a le soutien de
Barack Obama qui se dit fier de son
ancien vice-président il écrit sur
Twitter let's get to work mettons-nous
au travail
nous avons le taux de chômage le plus
bas en 50 ans dit ce sénateur démocrate
le secteur privé a créé 12 millions
d'emplois mais les démocrates ont beau
vantés leurs accomplissements que ce
soit sur la loi sur l'infrastructure ou
encore sur l'environnement la majorité
des Américains ne veulent pas que Joe
Baden se représente le dernier sondage
NBC indique que 70% d'entre eux s'y
oppose
personne ne veut une reprise du duel
tromb Biden dit-il
inconcevable qu'il se représente dit-il
aux dernières élections ils ont triché
et patients
est déjà en campagne électorale et se
présente comme le candidat des syndicats
ensuite n'a pas construit l'Amérique
dit-il c'est la classe moyenne avec les
syndicats Donald Trump dit qu'avec Joe
Biden on est au bord d'une troisième
guerre mondiale et c'est reparti Biden
contre Trump prise de d'un scénario que
la majorité des Américains redoute ici
Radio-Canada Montréal